donald doit 525 dollars à michel le plus
simple et puis envoyé son argent par
virement interac donald n'a besoin que
de l'adresse courriel de michel mais
pour encaisser l'argent
michel devra répondre à une question de
sécurité préparé par donald
mais donald fait une erreur en écrivant
l'adresse de michel
en plus il envoie la réponse à la
question de sécurité à la même adresse
erronée qui est l'adresse une autre
michel quelque part sur terre
quelques jours plus tard michel s'étonne
de ne pas avoir reçu son argent
donald se rend compte de son erreur il
appelle sa banque qui lui dit qu'il n'y
a rien à faire
elle lui rappelle qu'en adhérant au
service de virement interac
il a convenu qu'il était responsable de
fournir l'adresse exacte du destinataire
et qu'il ne devait surtout pas donner la
réponse aux destinataires par courriel
le fin mot de l'histoire
si vous en voyez la réponse à la
question de sécurité par courriel votre
virement pourrait virer au cauchemar